we have fought many resource Wars around
the world and in fact there's this thing
called the resource curse you've heard
about probably but you know just Loosely
explains the countries that have the
most diamonds or oil and stuff they
often have the least the tolerant least
Democratic regimes and least open at
least to journalistic freedoms what are
the implications of this just from a
geopolitical standpoint just like with
nuclear weapons once someone proved it
was able to be done it wasn't all that
hard for others to reproduce unless
there's some sort of Secret Sauce which
is manageable or if there's some very
difficult technical fix that we keep top
secret it's hard for me to imagine it
would become the domain of one country
foreign